irgendwie ist das paradox schon mit
bloßem auge erkennen wir nach einiger
zeit beim blick in den nachthimmel
dass sich die sterne bewegen doch wie
kann das sein und wir können dieses
phänomen sogar mit einfachen mitteln
dokumentieren sprich fotografieren
übrigens ist das video in zusammenarbeit
mit der cd fotografie entstanden hier
und dann bekommt er sogar ein exemplar
kostenlos 15 user gibt es dreimal pro
woche schwanden sidos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist in kooperation mit der
ct fotografie entstanden dem fachmagazin
rund um digitale bilder und am ende
erwartet euch ein exemplar kostenlos
oder wenn er jetzt schon auf sieg liegt
und durch die unterstützung von ct
fotografie ist dieses video auch
komplett werbefrei rund 300 jahre ist es
her dass astronomen und astronomen
erkannten dass sich sterne bewegen bis
ins 18 jahrhundert aber ging die
wissenschaft davon aus dass eine christ
als fairer unsere erde umgibt und dass
daran die sterne befestigt sein die
eigenbewegung der sterne war eine
großartige entdeckung und ein wichtiger
schritt hin zu weiteren spektakulären
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
doch zu dieser zeit gingen fachleute
weltweit noch davon aus dass das
universum klein und überschaubar sei
ihnen war zwar klar dass planeten wie
jupiter und mars um die sonne laufen und
sich deswegen auch am himmel bewegen
anders schien es jedoch bei den sternen
zu sein die ja schließlich nacht für
nacht dasselbe muster bilden und diese
sternbilder hatten doch bereits die
menschen in der antike gedeutet vor rund
2100 jahren hatte ein griechischer
astronomen den bedeutendsten stern
katalog der antike zusammengestellt und
seitdem sind alle sternbilder wie etwa
orion oder andromeda nahezu unverändert
geblieben
so also lag die schlussfolgerung nahe
dass die sterne stillstehen doch dann
gelang es dem britischen astronomen
edmond halley die eigene bewegung der
sterne aufzuspüren dazu schrieb er im
jahr 1718
ich habe mir die mühe gemacht die
heutigen positionen der sterne mit den
daten der antiken beobachter wie toll
aus und trieb arisch zu vergleichen zu
meiner überraschung habe ich bemerkt
dass die drei hellen sternen aldebaran
seriös und aktuelles heute etwas anders
am himmel stehen als vor fast 2000
jahren
die abweichung dieser drei sterne war
also so groß dass man sie sogar mit dem
bloßen auge erkennen konnte und genau
das ließ nur die eine schlussfolgerung
zu
die sterne stehen alles andere als still
sie bewegen sich durch die kosmische
weiten und es gab noch eine weitere
super spannende erkenntnis nämlich dass
sich ungeheure dynamik e-mails
straßensystem abspielen der grund für
die bewegung der sterne sie um laufen in
einem gemeinsamen schwerefeld das
zentrum der milchstraße und zwar mit
ungeheuren geschwindigkeiten von
mehreren hundert kilometern pro sekunde
doch das ist so natürlich nicht auf den
ersten blick auszumachen klar denn die
sterne sind weit von uns entfernt anders
als die planeten unseres sonnensystems
die nur millionen kilometer von der erde
entfernt sind sind es bis zu den
nächsten sternen billionen kilometer
ohne hilfsmittel ist es auf eine solch
enorme distanz unmöglich sternen
wanderung zu erkennen oder gar zu
beobachten
mittlerweile beobachten astronomie teams
äußerst routiniert den lauf der sterne
mit hilfe der heutigen teleskope geht
das sehr präzise zum glück denn diese
beobachtung führen zu ganz neuen
spannenden erkenntnissen dazu der
physiker david walker aus hamburg die
eigene bewegung der sterne ist geradezu
ein messinstrument um zu bestimmen wie
viel masse sich innerhalb der stern bahn
befindet wo man misst zum beispiel die
rotation kurven der großen galaxien
draußen im weltall und hat auf diese
weise die dunkle materie entdeckt man
hat also herausgefunden dass man um die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit also die
eigenbewegung der dortigen sterne zu
erklären die existenz von viel mehr
masse voraussetzen muss als man
tatsächlich sieht in unserem kosmos gibt
es also eine menge materie die wir bis
heutzutage nicht aufspüren konnten oder
gar zu gesicht bekommen haben die rede
ist von der dunkle materie die sich
alleine durch ihre gravitation verrät
das ist bei uns ja immer wieder thema
hier auf dem kanal aber diese materie
diese dunkle materie ist immer noch
nicht belegt und diese falls sie
existiert hat auswirkungen auf die
bewegung der sterne sie laufen deutlich
schneller durch das all
als das ist die forschung allein durch
die gravitation die für uns sichtbar ist
erklären könnte genau 300 jahre nach der
entdeckung des britischen astronomen
statement haley übrigens gab es im jahr
2018 eine erfolgsmeldung von der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
mit hilfe ihrer satelliten gaia wurden
innerhalb von knapp zwei jahren
zahlreiche sterne präzise vermessen und
dass es äußerst spannend für die
wissenschaft wenn solche daten geben
hinweise darauf wie sich die milchstraße
entwickelt hat und auch dazu wie sie
aufgebaut ist insgesamt wurden mehr als
eine milliarde sterne vermessen auch
hinsicht ihrer bewegung im all und ihrer
position
so wurde eine neue karte erstellt die
von einigen himmelskörpern wirklich
aufschlussreiche steckbrief enthält
beispielsweise zur helligkeit der
oberflächentemperatur und der farbe dazu
schreibt die esa auf ihrer website die
veröffentlichten daten decken den
zeitraum zwischen dem 25
juli 2014 und dem 23 mai 2016 ab und
bestimmen die position von fast 1,7
milliarden sternen und zwar präziser als
je zuvor für einige der hellsten
beobachteten sterne wurde die jeweilige
position so genau definiert als wenn man
von der erde aus die genaue stelle eine
auf der mondoberfläche liegenden euro
münze feststellen könnte die rede ist
von dem zitat umfangreichsten stern
katalog der menschheitsgeschichte
hervorgebracht inklusive hochpräzise
messung von fast 1,7 milliarden sternen
in diesem katalog ist sowohl die
parallaxe als auch die
radialgeschwindigkeit zusätzlich von
mehr als 1,3 milliarden sternen zu
finden der stern der sich aus unserer
sicht am schnellsten bewegt ist übrigens
bannas pfeil stern es handelt sich um
einen roten zwerg stern der etwa ein
sechstel der masse unserer sonne
aufweist direkt nach alpha centauri
handelt es sich um das zweit nächste
stern system zur erde
ein internationales astronomenteam hatte
er es vor zwei jahren entdeckt dass ba
nach falsch lernt über einen planeten
verfügt dieser hat die 3 fache masse der
erde umkreist in 226 jahren einmal um
den stern herum und zwar in einer
entfernung von 60 millionen kilometern
doch bereits im jahr 1916 hatte der
stern war seine entdeckung für aufregung
gesorgt denn der us astronom etwa der
nassen bahn hatte bei messungen
herausgefunden dass sich dieser stern im
vergleich zu
anderen stern am himmel besonders
schnell bewegt seine eigenbewegung
beträgt rund zehn bogensekunden pro jahr
seit seiner entdeckung vor rund 100
jahren hat er sich um etwa einen halben
mond durchmesser am himmel bewegt und
das ist für einen stern
doch wie kann man sich die bewegung von
stern wirklich vorstellen es gibt zum
einen die eigenbewegung der sterne die
wanderungen sind aber so minimal dass
ein menschenleben meist außer bannas
falsch dann gar nicht lang genug sein
kann um diese winzigen veränderungen
wahrzunehmen
die eigenbewegung entsteht daher dass
alle sterne um das zentrum der
milchstraße drei sind neben banasch der
meist auch akkus eine eher große
eigenbewegung auf es handelt sich um 2,3
bogensekunden pro jahr
in 3000 jahren also bewegt sich dieser
stern um etwa zwei grad am himmel wenn
man sich diese eigenbewegung von sternen
näher anschaut muss man zwischen zwei
komponenten unterscheiden zum einen eben
die verschiebung eines sterns am himmel
die quer zu unserer sicht linie verläuft
dazu kommt aber auch noch die
sogenannten radialgeschwindigkeit
fachleute meinen damit die bewegung des
sterns von uns weg oder auf uns zu diese
können wir so nicht wahrnehmen doch
astronomie teams können diese
radialgeschwindigkeit messen und zwar
mit hilfe des so genannten dopplereffekt
den kennen wir alle aus dem alltag wenn
sich ein krankenwagen mit sirenen auf
uns zu bewegt ist der ton für uns höher
als wenn sich das fahrzeug von uns weg
bewegt der grund dafür liegt darin dass
der schall gestaucht und gedehnt wird
wenn der krankenwagen mitsamt serie
wegfährt klingt das sirenen heulen für
unsere ohren tiefer der schall wird
gedehnt bei schneller fahrt zu und
schiebt der krankenwagen die
schallwellen vor sich zusammen denn er
fährt quasi in sie hinein er wird
gestaucht die schallwellen hinter dem
wagen dagegen werden daneben
auseinandergezogen und die frequenz wird
kleiner genau das wird von physikerinnen
und physikern als sogenannter doppler
effekt bezeichnet um die bewegung von
stern zu messen ist aber nicht der
schale entscheiden den gibt es nämlich
da nicht sondern das licht bzw bestimmte
farben denn jeder stern besitzt ein
charakteristisches lichtspektrum dort
sind die sogenannten absorptions linien
zu sehen
die jeweils für ein bestimmtes
chemisches element stehen jede dieser
linien hat eine bestimmte position im
spektrum wenn sie sterne richtung erde
also auf uns zu bewegen werden
zu kürzen wählen und somit ins blau
verschoben die ihnen dagegen werden ins
rote verschoben wenn der stern sich von
uns weg bewegt in diesem kontext ist
auch noch der begriff parallaxe wichtig
mit dem die scheinbare positionsänderung
von sternen am himmel gemeint ist diese
aber werden von der jährlichen sonnen
umkreisung der erde hervorgerufen und
haben mit der tatsächlich bewegung der
sterne nichts zu tun und zusätzlich
lässt die erdrotation es so aussehen als
würden sich die sterne am himmel bewegen
und genau das können fotografien
fotografen ausnutzen denn mit einem
überschaubaren equipment kann man
wirklich easy spektakuläre und
künstlerische aufnahmen erzielen
lediglich ein wenig geduld muss man
mitbringen um einen stern spurenbild ein
star trek bild hinzubekommen
als location auch dass ein dunkles
plätzchen und dazu eine möglichst klare
nacht im vordergrund kann sich ruhig ein
fels ein berg oder einem buch befinden
das könnte das endergebnis zusätzlich
noch stärker machen
wichtig sind ein paar vor überlegungen
zum beispiel die frage wo der mond steht
erstrebenswert ist hier ein mittelweg
ein vollmond würde die sterne zu sehr
überstrahlen fehlt der mond bei der
fotosession dagegen haben könnte es
schwierigkeiten dabei geben die sterne
rauschfrei abzubilden auch die
himmelsrichtung ist entscheidend denn
daraus ergibt sich die spätere form der
star trails wenn die region um den
polarstern mit dem bild ist bilden sich
konzentrische kreise um ihn herum
zumindest dann wenn man sich als
fotograf in oder fotograf auf der
nordhalbkugel befindet gegenläufige
kreise dagegen entstehen am
himmelsäquator um möglichst ansehnliche
stern spuren zu erzeugen ist die
belichtungszeit entscheiden wenn diese
bestimmt die längen der strich von der
trick dabei mit hilfe einer software
lassen sich mehrere einzelbilder die
einen identischen bildausschnitt zeigen
übereinander legen in der fachsprache
wird das als stacking bezeichnet für
einen star trek der den stern verlauf
einer stunde nachbildet werden bei einer
belichtungszeit von je zehn sekunden 360
aufnahmen benötigt wenn man den
verschluss pro einzelbild 120 sekunden
lang offen lässt braucht es nur 30 fotos
wie genau das alles funktioniert erfahrt
ihr in der ct fotografie und als klicks
umzuschauen bekommt ihr jetzt sogar eine
digitale ausgabe gratis mit vielen
profiteams fundierten workshops und
spannenden how to anleitung außerdem
findet ihr dank der um
zahlreiche produkttests vom kameras
objektive und fotozubehör auf jeden fall
das richtige equipment probiert es aus
es kostet nichts alles was er dafür tun
müsst ihr sie auf den link zu klicken
oder unten in der video beschreibung und
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran